[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to Japan
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys I've been here in Japan
for three months and I can say that it
is my most favorite country in Asia that
I've been to so far now the reason for
this is because it's an amazing culture
of amazing people and if you're
wondering what is this by the way this
is the Imperial Palace right now I'm
gonna share with you ten amazing things
that you need to know a budget pan and
its culture let's get to it everything
in Japan works and I mean everything
works I'm so shocked by how beautifully
and effectively everything works buses
trains
airports restaurants
everything works efficiently like a
while oiled machine and is because of
the Japanese attention to and passion
for detail most of all they have pride
in their work
sushi Japan is the birthplace of sushi
you only eat real sushi in Japan many of
you know what sushi is but there are
many variations of sushi in Japan that
you might not know of it takes around
ten years for a sushi chef to master his
craft or even longer
[Music]
so when you eat sushi from a real sushi
chef it feels like a quick trip to
heaven well at least that's how I feel
come by
[Music]
nice Japan has a very hospitable culture
I love Japanese people because they are
immensely well-mannered and they won my
heart with their kindness but most of
all thoughtfulness and consideration I
have not experienced this anywhere else
in the whole world so if you come to
Japan show respect and humility Wow
check out Tokyo Tower
check it out check it out check out so
big Wow all right another thing about
Japan is that it is safe doesn't matter
what city you travel to here in Japan
Japanese people obey the law and in mind
their manners that's why you'll find
people asleep on trains
even women walking alone at night it
made me realize just how bad my
countries of Africa really is where we
have over 50 murders every day and ever
46 children are raped every day but in
Japan I feel safe and I have a peace of
mind the world can learn so much from
Japan Japan is very very clean apart
from being just very hygienic and clean
themselves Japanese people also keeps
their cities in Japan clean they've been
taught from a young age that you should
always take responsibility for cleaning
up your own garbage this is something
that the rest of the world can learn
from every morning you'll find a few
people that is cleaning the areas around
their home or work they're not street
leaners their office workers nurses
lawyers normal people again the world
can learn so much from Japan especially
countries like China for example I
haven't seen any other country in the
whole world that just throws their trash
on the streets like China but again we
all have a responsibility because we
won't have a society if we don't take
care of our environment
[Music]
another amazing thing from Japan is the
cherry blossom is a special flower for
the whole country because it's a
symbolic flower of spring which means
it's a time for renewal why is it so
famous across the world well in Japan
these cherry blossoms are called the
Sakura is also the national flower of
Japan is pretty special because it only
lasts for around a week I mean it lasts
for around 10 days maybe maximum two
weeks but each tree only carries those
flowers for seven days so it's pretty
special
it's also very cultural for Japanese
people to have a picnic underneath the
tree
[Music]
another thing I love about Japan is
punctuality everyone everywhere always
on time and even Japan's public
transport is world-famous for being on
time and I mean exactly on time to the
minute now we can always get more money
but we can never get more time and I
think the Japanese notice and that is
why they don't waste your time and also
expect you not to waste
there's think about it you might think
hey I'm just 10 minutes late no problem
but actually you stole ten minutes from
someone else's life causing them to wait
for you
[Music]
Japanese food sushi is not the only
thing that makes Japanese food one of
the most popular cuisines in the world
they have delicious mouth-watering food
like ramen tempura curry rice
okonomiyaki shabu shabu miso soup
[Music]
takoyaki
[Applause]
this is takoyaki Sakura
[Music]
[Applause]
you go on onigiri soba and a lot more
other types of food so if you do come to
Japan you cannot miss out on any of
these yummy dishes privacy this is
amazing even in Tokyo were 38 million
people which is a lot more than the
whole of Australia with about 25 million
you are still able to experience privacy
in Tokyo Japanese people take privacy
very seriously so in public places
people are expected to consider how they
are invading people's privacy and should
refrain from doing so so it will be
wrong if you have a private conversation
on the phone if there are other people
around you that can hear what you are
saying because you're actually forcing
them to listen to you you need to
understand this a lot of people work
long hours here in Japan and they use
the time on trains or buses in Japan to
sleep think or just calmly reading so
the trainer bus rides are regarded as
having some peace and quiet be extremely
rude to talk loud on public transport
[Music]
vending machines they're everywhere
vending machines in Japan are awesome
and they're everywhere they're almost
around every corner
[Music]
you guys know that I love coffee right
coffee combined well you can find cold
and hot coffee in the vending machines
of course you can also buy a lot of
other things as well it became so
popular here in Japan that a lot of
restaurants started to implement vending
machines as well so it's easier for
people to order food all right guys on
the next episode I'm gonna show you my
model apartment and also what it is like
to do modeling here in Japan as a
foreigner see you next time
[Music]
[Music]